[Applause]
when populist politician Gert Builder's
party won most seats in the Dutch
election in November some in the
Netherlands were shocked for years his
anti-muslim anti-immigration rhetoric
had confined him to the margins of
politics but suddenly voters had
propelled him to the mainstream reacting
to Builder's victory at a meeting in
Portugal other European farite leaders
with similar policies said it was a sign
of what's to
come it's no coincidence that in many
European countries elections are won by
parties that defend the nation the
reality is that globalization is in
Retreat nations are making a
comeback this is a meeting between
winning parties between parties that are
going to change the face of
Europe changing the face of Europe is
the goal for far-right parties in June's
European parliamentary elections 400
million people across the EU are
eligible to vote for 720 seats top voter
concerns this year are expected to be
jobs security climate change the war in
Ukraine and
immigration immigration is the main
issue linking Europe's far-right party
some want to try and stop it all
together others want to greatly reduce
the number of people allowed into the
block that is a model we we see in more
places in Europe um the afda the altif
for dut land in Germany is growing uh
the party of mar Leen uh is still
growing and if we look at prognosis for
the next European Parliament election we
see a shift towards the right um there
as well that would have a a very
significant impact on policymaking there
as well for now the farri block is the
sixth largest in the EU Parliament
behind liberal conservative and green
groups but populist leaders are hoping
to become the third largest Force if
they do some fear that EU values
including human rights and the rule of
law could be threatened Natasha Al jazer
Paris make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer